de lo simple a lo complejo un marco
interpretativo en materia de las
políticas públicas es nuestra próxima
exposición cuánto puede influir en la
práctica de las políticas públicas del
recibir como herencia el apellido
paterno por ejemplo estos tres son tal
vez son temas que por ahí pueden pasar
desapercibidos pero que vale la pena
también analizarlos y junto a esta
presentación pues presentamos a que él y
vargas ella es trabajadora social y
especialista en análisis de políticas
públicas de la universidad nacional de
colombia también es máster de gobierno y
administración pública por la
universidad complutense de madrid y
candidata a doctorado en ciencias
políticas de la administración y
relaciones internacionales en este mismo
centro de educación superior con ustedes
damos la bienvenida a kelly vargas para
esta presentación
[Aplausos]
muy buenos días compañeros y compañeras
para mí es un placer compartir esta
experiencia individual y familiar que
hoy quiero transmitirles y que lo estoy
enmarcando también en un marco
interpretativo de política pública
durante la presentación me acompañaran
algunas obras del maestro oswaldo
guayasamín un poco reconociendo ese
valor de su obra humanista e indigenista
expresionista que nos hace mirar un poco
esos contrastes de esas situaciones que
son injustas y que son evitables sobre
todo y también nos lleva un poco a
entender como el artista va de esa de
esa serie de la ira a la serie de la
ternura que es la que le dedica a su
madre para construir y para generar un
proceso de reflexión
también voy a traer un poco a colación
el pensamiento aristotélico cuando nos
dice que los hombres y en este caso las
mujeres deberíamos hacer lo que es
correcto y no lo que está establecido
porque no todo lo que está establecido
debería ser así de hecho muchas de las
acciones que se han cometido en contra
de personas afrodescendientes de
comunidades indígenas comunidades room
personas diversamente función o las
personas con discapacidad en contra de
las mujeres es algo que debemos de
construir y que justamente hemos ido
avanzando en ese goce y en esa garantía
de derechos entonces sí es importante
desnaturalizar las prácticas que tenemos
y entender que todo el marco legal todo
el marco social no siempre es lo que
deberíamos apostar como sociedad
atrevernos a pensar y hacer cosas
distintas que busquen es que vivamos en
sociedades más libres y más igualitarias
mi presentación pues está fundamentada
tiene nombres y apellidos se llama juan
martín vargas coronel mi amado hijo de
un año tiene primero mi apellido materno
y posteriormente el de su padre
y nosotros habíamos pensado esto mucho
antes incluso de que nuestro hijo
estuviese en mi vientre muchas personas
piensan en los nombres y entonces dicen
es lindo recordar a mi madre a mi abuela
a alguien que yo admiro o le dan un
valor a un significado al nombre con el
que van a crecer sus hijos a sus hijas
nosotros hicimos muchas disertaciones y
discusiones alrededor de qué es lo que
realmente queremos transmitir en la
forma en cómo denominamos a nuestro hijo
y aquí comenzamos a discutir el tema de
los apellidos y qué es lo que
naturalmente se hace que los hombres
heredan el apellido a sus hijos y muchos
hombres quieren tener un hijo como mi
padre quiso siempre tener un hijo pero
nunca nunca lo logro ahora es muy feliz
porque mi hijo lleva su apellido de su
padre que le permite trascender a él
desde obviamente una mirada patriarcal
que por supuesto ahora les voy a contar
un poco que discusiones nos ha llevado
eso con mi padre
pero justamente entender que en esa
lógica patriarcal se hereda el apellido
del padre como una forma de reconocer a
los hombres finalmente en una estructura
sociológica que busca determinar un
marco económico y un marco también de
reconocimiento social de a qué familia
pertenezco yo sin embargo nosotros
creemos que el orden de los apellidos no
altera el amor ni la construcción del
sujeto que los objetos no son los
apellidos que tienen que deberíamos
generar un proceso de transformación
donde el sujeto se reconozca en función
de lo que hace por sí mismo y por los
demás y por el tiempo y espacio que deja
para otros y otras ojalá un poco mejor
de lo que encuentro entonces nosotros
con el padre de mi hijo hacemos un
proceso de construcción y de
construcción de lo que naturalmente
hemos establecido como un deber ser pero
aquí también hago una una reflexión
porque la política pública que está de
fondo aquí es la política pública para
la igualdad de género esta es una forma
de materializar uno de los lineamientos
de la política pública
pero esa política pública que tiene una
acción muy sencilla y que se materializa
a través de este tipo de acciones
requiere seres humanos comprometidos con
ello es decir no es un tema académico no
es un tema gubernamental es un tema
también individual y requiere de hombres
que permitan que mujeres como yo
tengamos una vida libre de violencias
que tengamos unas condiciones mejores y
que nuestros hijos crezcan en una lógica
más equitativa
es una decisión de pareja consciente y
comprometida por supuesto que tiene una
historia en mi caso pues yo tengo una
formación política e ideológica
transgresora pero basada un poco en
avanzar en procesos y en sociedades más
justas en diferentes temas no solamente
digamos en el tema de género que es un
tema que me aboca como mujer
pero también en otros temas por ejemplo
el de las personas con orientaciones
sexuales e identidades de género
diversas no siempre tenemos que
pertenecer al grupo que defendemos a la
causa que defendemos yo en lo personal y
en lo profesional aportó y trató de
construir conocimiento alrededor por
ejemplo este tema de las personas el eje
betty y cuando me acerco a ciertas
conferencias o lugares donde se hacen
discusiones sobre el tema a veces voy
con mi hijo y la gente no entiende muy
bien porque tengo que ser lesbiana para
estar ahí y tengo que ser transgénero
para estar ahí no los niños y las niñas
nos tienen que doler así no tenga un
niño o una niña en la calidad del agua
del aire son temas que pasan por las
macropolíticas que nos tocan en lo
personal pero que a veces un poco no lo
reconocemos en el caso de mi compañero
del padre de mi hijo hay una historia
especial su abuela que es una mujer
humilde una mujer de con una educación
muy básica con recursos muy limitados
hace un ejercicio de pensar que tal vez
sus hijas pueden tener una una vida
distinta a la que ella tenía
y en un lugar apartado en una vereda de
12 familias en la provincia de
chimborazo ella decide que su familia
ella y su esposo deben invertir en la
educación superior de sus hijas que en
ese momento no es un deseable social
invertir en la educación de una mujer
para que mejor que se encuentre un buen
esposo pero no ella decide apostar el
dinero que tiene sus ahorros y demás a
dar esa formación a sus hijas esas hijas
son las madres y tías de mi esposo que
han acompañado su proceso y su tras
correr vital y esa madre y esas tías le
han permitido a él también a través de
la movilidad social que tuvieron en la
educación que realmente la que nos
permite una transformación social tener
una postura política argumentativa
distinta entonces le dan vida a ese otro
ser humano que a su vez ahora le da la
posibilidad a mi hijo de tener otro
escenario distinto de vida
tuvimos dudas tuvimos temores y tuvimos
muchos desafíos este es un tema que
parece sencillo ir a la registraduría
decir no primero a me he perdido y luego
el de el papá es algo es un
procedimiento administrativo sencillo
pero de base no lo es tanto tiene luchas
y transformaciones que han sido
absolutamente relevantes tiene
discusiones políticas jurídicas
institucionales que hacen que se le dé
vida a esa política pública y que tiene
un devenir histórico que no es nada
sencillo
nosotros estuvimos a punto de decir
dejemos mejor el apellido del papá y
luego el mío si queremos apostarle a un
sujeto distinto no tenemos que hacer
necesariamente eso podemos hacerlo desde
la educación desde la construcción de lo
cotidiano pero también decíamos porque
vamos a renunciar a ella
si finalmente no creemos que un apellido
sea más importante que el otro pero si
estamos generando una reflexión y un
digamos y una consternación individual y
familiar incluso social frente a lo que
significa eso por qué
a nivel familiar muchas lágrimas esta
decisión después de que me dicen a mí
que tengo voy a tener un niño y le
comunicamos a la familia no el nombre y
el apellido que le vamos a poner la
abuela paterna entra en depresión de
verdad casi que en un llanto permanente
se aleja la familia paterna entonces
nosotros hacemos una proceso de
gestación un poco solos porque no
comprenden cuál es la razón
la abuela paterna señala que tal vez es
una vergüenza familiar que su hijo no se
siente
digamos no siente orgullo de su familia
y que por vergüenza familiar prefiere
que su apellido vaya en el segundo lugar
frente a todas esas tensiones que
comenzamos a tener yo le escribo un día
a ella un mensaje y le pregunto si es
que
si su hijo sintiera una vergüenza
familiar y por eso va en el segundo
lugar
quiere decir que el segundo apellido es
una vergüenza familiar y ese lugar está
para nosotras las mujeres sí porque ella
también es mujer y se lo pregunto y
también comienza a hacer una serie de
cuestionamientos sin pensar diferente no
es lo que nos permite transformar tus es
decir si no hubiéramos cuestionado la
esclavitud de la parte y demás
situaciones que nos han llevado a la
presión a la discriminación hoy nosotros
las mujeres no tendríamos derecho al
voto a la propiedad privada a decidir
sobre nuestro cuerpo a educarnos y es
esa posibilidades y por qué no y por qué
no hacerlo de otra manera cuando
comenzamos a cuestionarnos las
situaciones que vivimos podemos
construir otros escenarios mucho más
inclusivos para todos y para todas
en ese mismo mensaje le invito a ella a
disfrutar de esa vida que crece más allá
del apellido que tenga él en su nieto
disfrútelo porque es un privilegio tener
esa posibilidad máxime cuando nosotros
tuvimos muchas dificultades para tener a
nuestro bebé mi padre como les decía en
esa lógica de felicidad absoluta de por
fin tener con quien trascender su
apellido luego otro día hace una
reflexión y dice pensándolo mejor tal
vez yo hubiera querido tener el apellido
de mi madre porque mi madre significo
demasiado en mi vida y como me hubiera
gustado mejores y entonces esa misma
reflexión que es un poco en contra
lógica de lo que él mismo lo que él
mismo ha sido construido y aquí les
invito a pensar a todos y todas si tal
vez en algún momento ustedes también
dijeran si hubiese tenido esa
posibilidad me hubiera gustado no me
hubiera gustado o mis hijos me gustaría
que fueran así y martín mi hijo puede en
algún momento decir cuando tenga mi
compañera y tenga un hijo quiero que mi
compañera tenga primero su apellido y no
pasa nada ahí no tendríamos ningún
problema ojalá nosotros le ponemos a un
ser
de tener unas apuestas distintas a las
nuestras y argumentativamente crearnos
otros escenarios posibles
en dificultades institucionales también
hemos tenido muchos en las salidas del
país todos los formatos bien diseñados
apoyo paterno apellido materno entonces
todas las situaciones administrativas e
institucionales son sumamente engorrosa
si la gente no comprende no lo alcanza a
entender un poco y siempre piensan que
soy madre soltera bueno es una serie que
no tengo ningún problema y además admiro
a las mujeres si a mí se me ha hecho un
poco tan complejo el proceso de crianza
con un compañero como con el que tengo
no me imagino sola así que valoro
profundamente eso y no creo que a veces
cuando se dice es que van a pensar que
eres así pero es que una mujer que logre
sacar adelante a sus hijos sola que es
muy de admirar esa situación
y como les digo vamos de lo simple a lo
complejo desde que despertamos vivimos
en política pública si tenemos o no
tenemos un techo si tenemos o no tenemos
agua la cablería del aire que respiramos
los alimentos que le podemos que podemos
consumir que podemos enviar a quienes
tienen hijos oa sus familiares todas las
acciones cotidianas están transversal
izadas por política pública por eso sí
debe ser de interés de nosotros como
individuos entender qué está pasando en
la definición de lineamientos y las
políticas no son estables e inamovibles
son capaces de reformularse y de
repensarse antes no existían los
derechos del medio ambiente hoy existe
porque alguien considera que es
importante antes las personas del gti no
tenían derecho de hecho eran penalizadas
vamos a ver aún un delito hoy si lo
tienen y además se defiende y se procura
un bienestar entonces las políticas
públicas que finalmente están en el
marco del enfoque de derechos es decir
de la garantía que cada un y cada una
tenemos por ser el hecho de existir este
era un ser humano y la dignidad que eso
nos conlleva
se soporta en el enfoque de derechos que
es un enfoque universal indivisible
inalienable interdependiente no puedo
tener salud y no tener derecho a la vida
o tener derecho a la educación pero no
tener derecho a la recreación los
derechos son holístico si los seres
humanos deberíamos apostar que todos
tuviéramos estos derechos y en esa
lógica las políticas públicas buscan
responder a situaciones socialmente
problemáticas desde estos lineamientos
y por último decirles que vale la pena
que vale la pena atreverse a hacer cosas
distintas lo que es distinto genera
siempre tensiones genera dificultades y
eso nos pasa a todos y todos en muchos
escenarios pero cuando tengamos una
convicción cuando tengamos una pasión
creo que hay que vivir y hay que
apostarle a eso porque más adelante
seguramente otras personas se inspirarán
y entenderán y reflexionarán frente al
papel de lo que hoy estamos haciendo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]